[موسيقى]
سماء لا تهدا
وجدران بيت لا تستر زارتهم قذيفه
دمرت في طريقها ما استطاعت وتركت شظاياها
اثرا
رصاصات ايضا لم تبخل على المكان كارثه
خلفت وفاه شهد اهلها على وقوعها بل الرئيس
يا ريش
طوال خش عليه
يعني لحظات الاخيره
موت في لحظه كما الفقد وقع على هؤلاء
الاطفال
توفيت والدتهم امام اعينهم يتفقدون ما حل
بمنزلهم او ما خلفته الحرب على طفولتهم
اختار اهل الدار البقاء فلا خيار للنزوح
على بعد مسافه دمار لم يبقي شيئا خراب على
مد البصر كارثه بالدليل قذيفه حرقت
الممتلكات هنا وهشمت ابواب الرزق
قوه الانفجار كل الدكاكين ده ابوابها
انكمشت وتحشمت من فوق يعني ما في حاجه
اصحاب المهن اليدويه يشكون حالهم يحتجون
امام نقابتهم لا يجمعهم هنا سوى البطاله
الان وادوات جمدتها الحرب ووضعتهم بين
فكيها ماذا
كيف يا جماعه الناس دي كلها سافرت مرقت
هجرت لكن
قد تطال الجميع استيراد الاحتياجات
الغذائيه توقف اما المخزون الحكومي فيشك
على الانتهاء وفق الامن الغذائي السوداني
مقومات الحياه ان توفرت حاليا فاسعارها
مضاعفه
معارك حرمتهم من حركه تجاريه كان يعتاش
عليها السودان المنهك اقتصاديا اصلا غيداء
السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات